Onto dimensions.
Dimensions are the things that we use to describe our facts.
I really like Ralph Campbell's description of them as the who, what,
when, where, how, and why associated with the event or fact.
These descriptive components are used in reports to group,
summarize, and filter data.
If you're not sure what fields you want to include in your dimensions,
a good trick is to talk through what different ways you'd want
to slice and dice your data for reporting and look for by phrases.
If, for example, your boss says she wants to see all sales by fruit type, fiscal quarter,
and regional store location,
this can help you identify the fields that she will be looking for,
and that you'll want to ensure that you include on
the relevant dimensions so they're available for your report.
In the grocery store example,
you can imagine that there's a wealth of information
about the products being purchased on the product dimension.
This will be your what.
The timing of when the purchases were made on the date dimension, this is your when.
Which store a customer bought those items in on the store dimension,
which would serve as your where.
Some information on you via your loyalty card on the customer dimension,
which would be your who.
If we look at the sales transaction fact table,
your customer ID might be associated with many individual sales over
time at your local grocery store with your customer ID listed for each one.
But you and your customer ID number would
only show up once in the customer dimension table.
This makes it easy for us to reference
additional customer information about you and associate it with
those purchases when we need it while still
keeping the transactional data trim on the fact table.
I mentioned earlier that you want to have dimensions that are in plain
English rather than obscure acronyms or number codes.
Let's look at a concrete example.
Here on the left hand of the slide,
we have loyalty tiers for the same customer dimension that we looked at a moment ago.
As you can see, this tier grouping is being used to calculate
an average of monthly purchases for customers that fall into those categories.
At the bottom, you can see that the loyalty tier becomes
the ledger name for each of these groups' individualization.
Both the dimensions column name and
the dimensional data within the column tend to show up on the report itself.
It's best to make sure they are both unambiguous and easy to read.